-Today is
Martin Luther King Day.
Here to celebrate is one
of our writers.
Please give it up
for Amber Ruffin, everyone.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Get up and shout, Yay! ♪
♪ It's Martin Luther King Day ♪
♪ It's a day we look upon ♪
♪ With happiness and cheer ♪
♪ Get up and shout, Yay! ♪
♪ It's Martin Luther King Day ♪
♪ It's the day we remember ♪
♪ What he was fightin' for ♪
♪♪
♪ A bunch of laws were made ♪
♪ To keep Black people
oppressed ♪
♪ So Black people organized ♪
♪ To try to clean this mess ♪
♪ So MLK said, Hey, America? ♪
♪ We want civil rights ♪
♪ And they said, Mm, maybe ♪
♪ Just not as much as whites ♪
♪ A lot of white people
got upset ♪
♪ That we even dared to ask ♪
♪ And that's
the really crazy part ♪
So let's spend
some time there.
They hated Black people so bad,
[ Laughter ]
they couldn't even sit next
to them on a bus!
And they didn't just go away.
They're still alive and voting.
Like people always look
at the civil rights movement
as like this little bit of time,
but it lasted for [bleep] ever!
[ Laughter ]
And it's still kind of going on!
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ Get up and shout, Yay! ♪
♪ It's Martin Luther King Day ♪
♪ It's a day we look upon ♪
♪ With happiness and cheer ♪
♪ Get up and shout, Yay! ♪
♪ It's Martin Luther King Day ♪
♪ If you love freedom ♪
♪ It's the best day
of the year ♪
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
♪ So MLK makes me go, Yay! ♪
'Cause it's like dang!
[ Laughter ]
You know, we're always talking
about white supremacy and how
like it's a few idiots,
but it's a lotta people.
It's what killed
Martin Luther King
and it's still around and that
[bleep] is infuriating!
Like calling out injustice
all the time
can really get a person down.
-Whoo!
Like you could literally
be pointing it out
all day, every day,
and you wouldn't get it all!
But it's like,
if you don't do it,
who else is gonna do it?
You feel like
this huge mountain,
it's this huge mountain
you couldn't possibly
make a dent in.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, MLK was
always hopeful, so like...
[ Cheer ]
...I choose to be hopeful, too.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ Get up and shout, Yay! ♪
-♪ Yay! ♪
♪ It's Martin Luther King Day
Oh, yeah! ♪
♪ It's a day we understand ♪
♪ How great we all can be ♪
♪ Get up and shout ♪
-♪ Yay! ♪
-♪ It's Martin Luther King Day ♪
♪ If you love freedom ♪
♪ It's the best day ♪
♪ Of the year! ♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!